welcome back to new rock stars I got
some my I that time mmm supposed to go
in the hey this is the big question
quarantine Edition it's a show that
gives you too much information about the
stuff that's too dark even for Rick and
Morty
yikes I'm Erik Bosse here with Philip
Malina how you doing man I'm doing good
I feel good today I've decided I'm going
to embrace however long we're stuck in
this life and this is just me now
I'm just someone who doesn't exist
outside everybody thought you were dead
sorry uh-huh this is the new normal this
is default Philip and Eric this is a
what we're always born to be evolution
ends right here
I don't remember the before times
anymore the the before four and now
we're in the true-true
Eric what's my big question as me
purpose well Rick and Morty Season 4 is
coming back this weekend so exciting and
throughout these four seasons of Rick
and Morty the writers have hinted at
this long-running secret that might not
get revealed until the very end of the
series so I want to know from you Philip
what is this secret Rick and Morty plot
twist that they're saving for the series
finale probably why would I know because
your fellow Molina and I'm Erik Bosse
and we just know things and that's why
people ask us these big questions that's
true I actually do know I know exactly
what it is ha ha ha knew it or I know
full of the four or five most likely
possibilities and I've ranked these by
likelihood and mind-blowing right yes so
it's either something that's likely or
something that's exciting
yeah exactly remember a boy would risk a
version of that movie about that kid
growing up and becoming a porn star no
but I'll be googling something this
after we're done taping
okay
so what happened was in season one of
Rick and Morty Dan Harmon gave an
interview or between season 1 season 2
and he was talking about the big Rick
and Morty secret that they'd been
talking about in the writers room that
nobody would ever know maybe at the very
end they'd finally reveal it and then he
was later referencing it again and
realized that someone on reddit had
already potentially guessed it they
always do they always do so he wouldn't
say which of the popular theories it
could be but I've spent too much time
looking at what all the possibilities
could be and then narrowing it down to
just kind of what feels like the show is
potentially headed toward and also what
feels like would be satisfying
so first possibility for the deep dark
series long secret and that is that Rick
Sanchez knows that not only is Tiana TV
show but that he's specifically a
cartoon character alright yeah and we've
kind of seen a lot of things like these
these meta jokes right even in the pilot
it you know famously ends with all the
like him ranting about the adventures
they're gonna go on which kind of sounds
like episodes but he specifically says
WWE are in Morecambe just their actual
website yeah but then they like triple
down on that right at the in the season
finale of that season he says then in
season two he says they'll be back after
a commercial break yeah in look who's
purging now he has her mind Morty about
what happened in the first act of the
episode sure in season 3 he says I want
that Mulan McNugget stops morning
that's my series our world it takes nine
seasons shut your mouth diphthong where
and fatty there's another commercial
break we says we'll be right back and in
a Rick and Jerry episode he yells out
it's a Ricky Jerry's picture
what's also interesting about this is
that it's not only him sometimes it
seems like other characters too but
specifically mr. poopy butthole
definitely seems to also know this
because he talks to the audience during
the credits multiple times he said
previously goodbye until season four in
a really long time so actually aware of
also the production schedule of the show
so my grading on this is like likelihood
yeah hundred percent this is this is
true this has to be true we've seen it
too many times so I actually put it on
very low mind blow yeah this isn't even
much of a secret this is a true facet to
Rick's character that he can break the
fourth wall he's like Deadpool or Howard
the Duck or you know he's someone who
doesn't see the barrier between us in
the fictional world of the show the only
way that that would be satisfying and
and mind-blowing is if the final season
or the final episodes really deal with
this you know it's about like you
watching your reality is at risk and
we're gonna try to save you guys and
it's like that episode of The Simpsons
where Homer ends up in our world by
accident oh yeah and the 3d treehouse of
horror early CGI yeah that was amazing
that would be crazy if Rick and Morty
tried to do like a live stream animated
thing where they have a
choose-your-own-adventure in the
audience can kind of like vote along
like Bandersnatch Rick and Morty fans
definitely vote to end it all yeah
immediately I'm sorry but so yeah he
knows he's a fictional character like
Erik Bosse
[Music]
so up next on theories this one actually
makes a lot of sense but I actually
hadn't heard it that much it's the
possibility it's not gonna sound that
crazy until you think about the
consequences that Rick is then has
always been drinking mega seed juice and
that's actually that that spiky seed
that goes up Morty's butt in the pilot
they they really show it's real graphic
which means that this would
theoretically have been set up all the
way back in the pilot and why that
matters at all is because we the whole
series have gotten really used to Rick
drinking from a flask it's not only a
hint that he's a terrible alcoholic but
also it's specifically the blast that's
interesting because you don't actually
see him binging on beer bottles and you
know bottles of vodka it's his own
private flask that he's constantly going
back into and then here's the why if you
remember in that pilot episode morty
drinks from that juice and he suddenly
is brilliant for a fleeting second
increment in the internal energy of the
system is equal to the increment of heat
supplied to the system wow i'm so smart
that's right he's able to like lie to
his parents and come up with like an
amazing plausible story that falls right
off of one sip of the thing now if rick
has been drinking it non-stop then that
would explain his not only above-average
intelligence he's the smartest being in
the universe yeah the multiverse Linda
right yeah
now while that makes a lot of sense I
actually love if you think about this
one little bit of evidence that would
have again been planted in the pilot we
show an image on screen of when Morty
drinks it if you look at the little
dribble that comes out of his mouth it's
blue which is what Rick always has that
bluish dribble always coming out of his
mouth which doesn't really make sense
for it to be vodka or something I always
just assumed that's just like you know
they show water any raindrop is blue but
you know Rick and Morty's animation
doesn't always stick to those kind of
old-school style animation coloring
tropes like yeah if it is colored blue
it might be like the reason meeseeks are
blue it's a choice and especially to
make it the same as what morty has on
his face
that's what i drinking from the seed for
likelihood i actually because of that
detail put it pretty high I'm gonna put
it at 70% and I'm gonna put a mid-level
insanity like the mind blow is decent
because it means Rick is not that smart
he's cheating which of course he's to
cheat if even if you have that why not
yeah you know and that doesn't make
sense why Rick would have an edge over
all the other Rick's like every Rick is
like pretty smart but he's able to like
outsmart every single other Rick he
needs some he had a test him you know
there's something enhancing his
performance and maybe it's the mega C
juice and worth noting that's a seed
that he wasn't able to go to some
intergalactic liquor store or clinic of
some sort they had to go find this seed
in this kind of barren wasteland so it
might be a thing that he discovered and
has kind of kept to himself yeah I buy
that boom so 70% on that mild mind blow
number 3 this one I had heard before but
it doesn't make some sense and that is
that Rick Sanchez is actually just an
older Morty I like this theory do you
like it I like what do you think about
the other ones they're interesting but I
kind of take them as like true already
this one seems just on that on the
ballots of Fringe ok so one of the
easiest pieces of evidence for this is
the fact that both characters are
literally voiced by Justin roiland oh so
it's the same dude giving the young
voice and the old voice hey Morty what
do you think of our moderator Rick he
seems like a real flop sweaty sort of
douchebag but I don't I don't like that
kind of evidence
I like in-world evidence uh-huh and this
would explain why we often see Rick as
apathetic toward danger but if he's
actually future Morty and he knows that
he lives to be this old man then he
actually knows that he doesn't have to
worry about Morty he lets more to get
you know bitten by things and hid just
constantly seem like he's about to die
but he knows that he survives all of
those things because he is that Morty
okay yeah I see that it does introduce
and I am my own grandfather problem yeah
that's right he's the predestination
thing all in a nutshell and now I must
bleep with the sexiest woman here who is
also my grandmother Laura I will cease
to exist how do you know I'm not chicken
now there is a version of this theory
that gets like extra weird where it's
not morty from the future it's actually
a current morty who's from a dimension
where time goes much faster and has left
that dimension so he aged into being
older and then switched over it is now
in this dimension the only reason why I
think that's even worth mentioning is
there's the scene in the first episode
you know how Morty breaks his legs
terribly Rick specifically says I went
into a future dimension with such
advanced medicine that they had broken
leg serum at every corner drugstore so
they actually have introduced this idea
that it's not just linear side by side
dimensions but also some dimensions at
least seem to have a different time
floor yeah that's true so likelihood
just on the part where Rick is older
Morty
I'm putting around 63 percent this is
very scientific where you know it's not
the craziest thing the reason I put
above 50% in that it's more likely than
not is because it feels like the kind of
thing that if you zoom out for this
series the creators would feel like
that'd be a word they'd pay off to
reveal that the you know Morty is
destined to become Rick this is who he's
gonna be that's why I think it actually
could happen and it's pretty insane it's
a pretty mind-blowing yeah I agree that
is something that feels like Rick and
Morty to show that as shown everything
is plausible and possible in this
multiverse so like that is something
that even as a joke they could put that
in there's like a throwaway joke in the
finale that isn't meant to be
mind-blowing it's just like yeah there's
reality where Morty grows up to become
his own grandfather yeah it's possible
now forget that very very erase it thank
you
this one I actually like more and that's
that Morty big secret for the whole
series is not the original Morty Oh what
that means we've been misled this whole
time about why these adventure started
and how things got going at the
beginning the truth would actually be
and spoiler I'm gonna have a spin-off
theory in a second the
Ruth would actually be that Rick killed
the original Morty maybe by accident
maybe in a fit of rage as on his want to
do but then felt really terrible about
it went crazy went to another dimension
joint ammo Morty over into his dimension
maybe wiped his memory and that's the
Morty that we've been with this whole
time it would explain a couple of things
one in the episode Rick push number nine
a when they replace Rick and Morty in
that terribly dark episode Morty's super
traumatized as one should be Rick seems
like he's done this before oh absolutely
yeah so that's the easiest set up for
this idea but also in Total Recall Rick
tells Beth after she accidentally shoots
someone he says listen Beth don't be too
hard on yourself I made a similar
mistake years ago I mean accidentally
killed someone also Rick just having
this investment in Morty and wanting to
make sure he lives his interesting life
and goes on all these adventures that he
could definitely just do all the stuff
alone it could be because he wants to
make it up to this Morty for having
ended the life of a younger Morty a
previous Morty time for the spin-off
variable may be that Morty didn't die
but Rick thinks he did somehow through
cybernetic implants he survived and
became boom evil Morty oh yeah sure and
thus it would explain a plot toward
vengeance against Rick by his original
Morty that's as plausible of an origin
story for evil morty as i can think of
like he is the rick we know prime rick
like the primordial the prime rib i got
some taste for time rick that on that
side of michael's bone-in prime rick
gross mmm that's where the yummy savor
you Susan
I'm getting too erotic about talking
about me and putting their bone in I put
the likelihood of this I still put it at
55 percent I think it's so solid that I
think they might do it I just you know
don't think it's guaranteed but I think
that'd be pretty [ __ ] insane
I think that's mind blow that's your
mind blow 30 mind blowing I will say I
own your spin off theory I would say is
more around 55 percent but I think the
first part of your theory could be more
plausible just this idea that like
constantly different versions of them
from different sections of the
multiverse have been swapped in and out
I think the moment that happened in
brick potion number 9 it basically told
the audience hey all these characters
you're seeing are interchangeable with
other versions of them don't think about
it and the fact that they've stuck with
that an episode since I don't think
we're meant to be attached to anyone
more tea or even anyone Rick that at any
point think we swapped out they followed
up on this when the when Jerry was
swapped at the daycare you know it's
like is this the same Jerry probably not
if you look closely at the doesn't
matter yeah yeah I think the first
quarter your theory is almost like 99
percent but yeah that would be evil
Morty I agree this is about 5055 which
of those do you think is most likely in
which of those do you think would be
most satisfying I still think the the
most satisfying reveal that they could
do even we speculate on this before but
this idea that the Morty we're following
does grow up to become the Rick that
they're actually the the same people
just separate at different times in
their lives kind of the whole West world
trick you know where William becomes the
man in black they're the same person but
we did see some future versions of
Morty's hypothetical deaths in the
season four premiere right and we did
see an elderly version of him on his
deathbed but that was also a timeline
where he like fell into depression and
got overweight you know if he were to
transform into the Rick we know that
would be a very specific timeline in
which he devoted his mind to science he
was depressed and drank a different
thing and maybe like an advanced
advanced elderly version cuz we don't
know how old Rick is it was interesting
the drugs of years could be hundreds in
Rick's flashback in the season 3
premiere which also was like unreliable
narrator but he was still kind of old
with Beth's mother and young Beth so
this guy could be like hundreds
thousands of years old
one thing you
know if that's the ones right if you see
Morty's eyebrows start to come together
let's measure Morty's eyebrows every
episode just I already do all right Eric
those are what I would put money on to
be the big secret finale that we may or
may not ever learn about yeah especially
at the speed they put these episodes out
yeah we are decades away potentially but
hey the next episode comes out tonight I
think if it would depend on when you're
watching this episode so make sure to
stick with us we're gonna be doing
episodes over explained after shows
three episodes as well as additional
breakdowns where we break down all the
little animation jokes and Easter eggs
that they hide in the episodes we're
really excited every can Morty back
because otherwise not a lot of content
to talk about but you know really life
right now is a lot and I think Philip we
could use a bit more chill you know
maybe if you're watching this you could
be working from home like Phillip and I
are you can be dealing with like family
stress general life stress sometimes we
just need to hit pause and just chill as
you guys know we started doing our
Friday and meeting into drinking session
because we realize that it's a good time
for us to finally chill and now we
started allowing ourselves just a few
minutes to actually look at the current
news and discuss it and just let it all
out while we have some drinks and then
that's it we contain it within that time
it's a good way to look at the news in a
quick bite-sized while you have a drink
in your hand that's right and it's
honestly the most forgivable way to go
to some extremes and your diatribes and
your rants and everything that's wrong
with the world because eventually no one
remembers it and you just kind of soften
it and ultimately you look back on it as
a moment you chilled the best way we've
been able to do that is thanks to
referendum Coors Light as you know the
mountains on the Coors like cans and
bottles they turn blue when it's chilled
to perfection it's really just the
perfect barrier for chillin because it's
cold and crisp and it's really just 105
calories what it's why I'm allowed to
drink it but you're also allowed to
drink it or just choose it whenever you
need a moment of chill you need to reset
reach for the beer that's made to chill
and you can of course like delivered by
going to get dot Coors Light comm and
finding local delivery options near you
and hey wait hold on as you're partying
and
balloons are up and everything still
celebrate responsibly Coors Brewing
Company Golden Colorado yeah what was
that about you drinking responsibly you
won't bite that can and throw it with
your teeth no I have soft teeth like
Michael Scott
you just hear crash they're just jelly
beans Erik you ready to do bite size
question yeah speaking of your weak bite
[Music]
no it was headed toward baby dinosaur 4
ha all right you ready yeah
bite-sized questions for Erik Voss James
Jones at pilot Jim Jones asks in Lord of
the Rings this is the classic question
could the Eagles have just blown mother
flip and Frodo or anyone actually with
the ring just directly to Mordor let's
drop it in the freaking volcano be done
with it James thank you for falling on
the sword I don't know if you're
generally asking this or if you're just
asking it for all the other snark errs
out there this is the classic big
question question right okay to answer
it what's it for all know the great
Eagles could not have just simply flown
the ring themselves because they're
powerful beasts they cannot possess the
ring without being corrupted themselves
it has to be Eagles would be correct the
Eagles would be corrupted they're super
powerful beasts they're not beasts or
animals all animals are a good soul no I
mean all of us humans are animals elves
are animals not there's a big-ass baby
on Twitter right now that wants to fight
me looking like a star only the hobbits
are humble and capable enough of
sneaking into Mordor undetected on foot
while the Battle of the Black Gate kept
Sauron distracted so that Frodo and Sam
could reach the exact spot on Mount Doom
where the ring was forged and return it
to the fires from whence it came it had
to be the hobbits now the reason why the
Eagles couldn't just fly them to Mordor
is that before the Eye of Sauron crash a
murderous airspace was impenetrable I've
Sauron would've Amin
we spotted any huge-ass eagle swooping
in and then they would have sent off the
witch-king and its dragon who were also
airborne folks and would have shot them
down and taken the ring for themselves
they had to sneak in there on foot and
you know as warm air said one does not
simply walk into Mordor but yes he was
right but it wasn't simple obviously
they had to sneak in there and they
needed Gollum to guide them so the other
thing we need to point out is the great
Eagles do not serve Gandalf their
friends homie they're kind of equals but
the Eagles aren't gonna do themselves to
certain death just to do gandalf a solid
they did save Gandalf from Saruman and
the Fellowship of the Ring but it posed
at that point little risk to them to fly
into Mordor would be flying into certain
death so the only way they were able to
help in this situation was only after
the witch King had been slain after the
Eye of Sauron crashed down after the
Dark Lord's army the Black Gate had been
routed and the ring was destroyed of
course to wipe out saurons power then
the airspace was cleared for the Eagles
to help rescue Sam and Frodo now some
also believe that Tolkien based the
great Eagles on American delayed
intervention in world war two because
the the Wars of Lord of the Rings are
based on and that was never confirmed
even though Tolkien did kind of have a
disdain for American culture that's more
of like a literary interpretation but
yeah you could definitely draw some
parallels in the way you know some
Europeans saw the Americans swooping in
in the final years of world war two
after you know other countries spent
more lives to do the hard work but they
do serve a crucial role in rescuing the
heroes that interpretation has never
been confirmed again but that would be
another reason why the Eagles would come
in as a deus ex machina at the last
minute but that is what literary
according to Greek leader a deus ex
machina is something that comes in at
the last minute like that's that's just
basic storytelling I guess you're right
I just can't get over this thing new are
you saying the Eagles would become bad
everyone would become bad born here is a
wonderful man in which moment men are
easily corrupted case in point us I
don't know it's just so sad imagine look
at Gollum Smeagol storyline but with
like a beautiful majestic eagle I see I
would have an argument for you if it you
didn't have that where the Eagles as
they approach could you know right on
the tip of their claws
the ring on and then they'd approach in
cloak mode the ring of power is that
corruptive it is the ultimate evil even
gandalf couldn't bear it and gandalf is
a wonderful wizard fine I'm okay with
that so how about another bite-sized hit
me with another one Carol on our discord
has been pumping him out but they've all
been pretty good Oh Carol BDC diva wants
to know why can't Mandalorians
take off their helmets in the
Mandalorian when Mandalorians and rebels
and clone wars easily take them off all
the freaking time
what changed yes this is a very good
question I'm happy to answer it so the
Mandalorian the series on Disney plus
takes place in the year nine ABY after
the Battle of Yavin which is about five
years after returned the Jedi currently
Clone Wars season seven is showing us
the siege of Mandalore which is set
around 19 BBY the same year as Revenge
of the Sith in order 66 now at that
point in time the Mandalorians don't
seem to have any kind of strict Ecole T
rules yet and also in rebels which is
you know the the last time we see them
is in one bdy right before the Battle of
Yavin Boat Catan we've seen rally in the
Mandalorian clans and yeah there's still
no colty this is the way there yet this
is the last we see of them checking in
10 years later in the Mandalorian yeah
they're all underground and they're
there they're weird and they're cold see
here's what changed somewhere in that 10
year period there was an additional
later siege of Mandalore this is
separate from the Republic siege of
Mandalore that were seen in the Clone
Wars this later siege of Mandalore was
an imperial siege that was led by Mothe
Gideon Gustavo Fring that siege was
horrible to the Mandalorian people it
wiped most of them out it spread them
out they lost most of their precious
relics and this is what led to them
going underground the Mandalorian group
who we meet in the Mandalorian series is
a specific survivor cult from that
disaster and they they now have decided
the one way they can survive is by
covering their faces and adopting these
strict rules that preserve their culture
and by trying to recover the culture and
all their stolen best scar so presumably
Mandalorian season 2 and the recently
announced season 3 will fill in this
backstory especially the characters like
ahsoka
joining the cast who is tied in with Bo
Catan at the end of revels Wow okay so a
lot of [ __ ] happened and they just kind
of like I'm glad that I just got that
answer now Carol says she has a follow
up here who's watching
recent videos and you used to be
willy-nilly about taking off your jacket
but now something needs a change in your
religion and you you really I love this
jacket
um layering is the way alright and
finally Cal sue on discord ass oh just
straightforward I think you know these
off the top of your head - uh-huh what
properties does Sony own okay so Sony
owns so much it's a massive technology
and entertainment conglomerate it owns
music licensing videa gaymes consumer
products tvs headphones speakers but
also a little thing called a Sony
Entertainment Group which bought the old
film studio Columbia TriStar they're two
differ ones they merged but the bottom
in the 80s and is now it is one of the
five big film studios along with Disney
Warner paramount Universal so they're
one of five Disney bought out Fox okay
so here's what they own the biggest one
that they own is spider-man but also all
of his associated titles including the
sinister six all the spy diverse
alternate spider-man venom carnage
Morbius black hat at one point Sony
claimed to own over nine hundred Marvel
titles most immortal comics are tied and
connected aspire to me and that's why
they're not wrong now when it comes to
spider-man just to clarify something
Disney does not co-owned spider-man
Disney is co-producing and co-financing
and co profiting off of these certain
specific limited deals with Sony for
spider-man three and another up tummy in
another up to me and another untitled
Marvel team-up film where Sony finances
and profits 75% Disney gets 25% but
Disney keeps all the merchandising
rights for spider-man which is where a
lot more money mix okay so what else is
Sony owned they also owned the very
profitable Jumanji film franchise come
on D Jumanji Dumbledore's e'en Jumanji
they also own ghostbusters which is very
profitable they made the film in 2016
but also they're doing the Ghostbusters
afterlife which is coming out next year
they own the men in black franchise they
own the bad boys franchise they also own
the Karate Kid franchise including all
the remakes and sequels and Cobra Kai
now also Sony of course owns a huge film
studio lot in Culver City which Los
Angeles real estate and studio space is
a very valuable thing that's how they
make a lot of their money
their film studios and production
companies shoot on their lot so they
produce shows like game shows they own a
lot of the game show network Wheel of
Fortune jeopardy they also produced
shows for other networks like community
Breaking Bad better call Saul if you see
a Sony logo at the end of these shows
and the credits
it means Sony had involvement with it
and they probably are making money
syndicating this content overseas so
that is how Sony makes all of its money
it's why it's not gonna be that easy for
Disney to just buy them out because they
don't just make their money from their
film and TV properties they make money
selling headphones and ps4s and all the
games that are associated with that and
you could say they probably make a lot
more money from that than they do from
their films anyway you're never gonna
get your Rain Man spider-man Iron Man
crossover calcio I'm sorry slash wheel
of fortune Eric it's time for our
mailbag the mailbag box of mystery
extravaganza why is it called a mailbag
when it's shaped like a question box oh
why don't we just call it the question
box too late it's episode all right it's
stupid so this just bought a bag have
bags
you can't stack a bag you can't stack a
bag you can't you cannot stack a bag
somebody got mad at me for touching my
face too much in the comments and it's
like I'm just alone my home yeah but I'm
really sure you're not doing
meet-and-greets after this speaking of
having people in your home mailbag
question question box why should dammit
what's the weirdest thing I guessed has
ever done in in our homes okay I have a
story that's kind of legendary in the
Voss family I'm from a big Navy family
there's a lot of filibus there's Nancy
Voss there's Katie Voss yeah yeah
there's a they're all the Navy slide
yeah I have a brother brother-in-law my
dad spent decades in the Navy so we
would have have these big Navy parties
at her house and around the time I dad
retired in the early 90s there was a
junior officer who was really drunk and
comes up to my mom and is complimenting
one of my sisters who was 10 years old
at the time and he said your daughter is
you
and my mom said she's 10 and the junior
officer goes I'll wait it what to your
mom oh wait I'll wait remind the viewers
that we are both from Florida where that
marriage is legal yeah it's a yeah you
can never get a judge to grant a divorce
from that marriage yeah this guy would
probably be late 20s early 30s not okay
not okay most ages not okay did he wait
yeah he waited there I'm 16
yeah there was a lot of that was one of
many probably wild and inappropriate
things that were going down at some of
these pool parties and my future which
one of your sisters there were other
sisters who were closer to the age of 18
that he that looked a little bit nice
illegal not his type not his type oh my
god I hate this yeah it's it's the most
disgusting and creepiest thing that has
ever happened and how did your parents
react well they kind of wrote it off at
the time he's like well he's drunk my
mom was horrified looks good we didn't
really have any other big Navy bashes at
her house because when my dad retired so
we didn't have any huge parties like
that this guy was someone that my dad
barely knew anyway but it's just like
when you have a party like this when
you're this when you're the XO of a
squadron you invite everyone over to
your house his retirement party yeah
it's like you're supposed to get a watch
but he give he presents a ring for your
sister god what a horrible man
yeah but thank you for his service yeah
sure yeah oh they came to mind for me
it's it's tough yeah I guess a place
that I lived where a guest did something
weird would be in Jennings hall the dorm
I lived in freshman year college Eagle
weeders lowriders yeah we got Jennings
Hall in the house I'm just trying to
finish my engineering assignments
I had friends visiting from Orlando one
weekend and they I mean we were freshmen
in college freshmen and so we got
trashed of course I won't say on what's
up since we were so gone I think we were
all we just hadn't seen each other in so
long
that we absolutely overdid it and we're
just like the most gone we'd ever been
and so of course we come back to the
dorms and like you don't have anywhere
to host people so people just stay in
your dorms and so a friend of mine who
was so messed up that we were worried
about him we did it we got home I like I
think it was like 4:00 a.m. and we do
that thing where a like two of us are
like how do you solve this without
getting this kid in trouble but he does
seem like he needs help and so one of
you I guess has seen it on TV or
somebody is like well you put them in
the shower you put the drunk person in
the shower and then the steam cures the
problem or something so we walk him over
to the shower and then we push them in
there we close the curtain and we're
like take a shower you need a shower and
he's like I don't know what everybody's
like so out of it so then we like reach
in and we we just turn on the water
anyway and he strips his clothes good
and and you know toss him aside and we
like we like gather them up whatever
went bring him a towel and then he just
like stays under the water for like a
super long time we're trying to wait
we're also kind of messed up so
eventually it's it's been like 15
minutes whatever and we're like how are
you doing in there and he throws open
the curtain and he's just totally naked
which we've never seen a naked person
but it's fine ourselves like woah okay
nevermind he's like I'm good man I'm
good taking a shower we're like okay so
we close it we're like how about we just
leave him in here he does seem like he's
better the shower medicine is working so
we go back into the room and then like
maybe 40 minutes later he comes back
from from the shower so it's like you
know almost 5:00 a.m. and he just like
passed out on the floor of the dorm room
we we all pass out pretty quickly - 6:30
a.m. I think maybe at the at the latest
pounding on all of the dorm room doors
it's the RA and he's just like everybody
out of the room everybody out of the
rooms I were like we just got asleep and
so we get woken up and we're all will
fill the hallway and he's I follow me
everybody has to follow him and he takes
us into the shower area and he pulls
back the curtain he's a which one of you
disgusting took a big-ass nasty [ __ ] in
this shower I and it was exactly the
shower that had just been in so we
immediately just me and the other friend
that words been taking care of him look
at the third friend who's still pretty
drunk
third friend clearly has no idea that it
was him he's just like crazy also you
doesn't even go to this school
it doesn't notice that it's everybody's
like go in there and he's like we're not
leaving this shower area staring at this
turd until somebody fesses up know and
so does that thing happens where
everybody's just like I mean it was
probably Darren right Darren that looks
like your thing right and Darren's just
like no I been asleep
we're like Darren stop lying and
eventually he's like Darren was of you
and if we're all it's like like 50 guys
basically are just staring this guy so
he's like I'm fine what if it wasn't me
and he's like then you need to clean it
up so Darren had to go pick up all and
then and then turn on the showerhead and
try to like rest out and that was the
weirdest thing that another guest had
done was [ __ ] in my shower and then
another guy had to clean it up what's so
tough about thinking about this as I was
running through stories in my head by
far I've done most of the weird things
in somebody else's house no yeah we're
gonna we're gonna find that out we're
gonna crack that Darren I know you watch
these videos I'm so sorry
hey Darren the shower [ __ ] be sure to
become a patron of the rock stories a
column you can join our discord well
that is our show as always we learn a
lot about each other it's such a
valuable experience to get to do this
every week reminder to all of you if you
haven't already joined our official
discord by becoming a patreon at
patreon.com slash new rock stars and you
can get an audio version of the show by
subscribing to new rock stars big
question where ever get your podcasts
and thanks to all of you as always to
submitted questions we love hearing from
you and you can send us your big
questions on twitter using the hashtag
big question or you can mail us anything
at our pierrot box address below and you
can follow me I da boss follow Phillip
at Phillip million fo new rock stars and
socials subscribe here on YouTube
to get too much information almost if
you care about see you next week fill up
and all of you Oh bye-bye
[Music]